hallo liebe leute wir sitzen hier mit
james jakes haben wir heute hier in köln
vor dem baum getroffen
zufällig du hast uns einfach
angesprochen james cook auch easyjet
willkommen danke für was wo kommst du
her aus texas und du hast uns gesagt du
kannst uns du guckst also offenbar easy
german baum guckst du sie zusammen weil
ich möchte deutsch lerne und das ist ein
langer prozess und ich bin sehr schlecht
deutsch jetzt aber versuche ich weiter
ein deutsches ganz gut was für einen
tipp hast du an die anderen zuschauer
zum deutschland was ist ein ultimativer
tipp
ja vielleicht ich glaube dass wenn ich
jede sendung jeder episode von easy
german schaut und dann jeder schaut und
so weiter und so ich jeder wort
verstehen können und jeder kann und
jeder wärter wiederholen
dann werde ich vielleicht ein bisschen
besser verstehen und sprechen also du
versuchst tatsächlich in jeder episode
die untertitel mitzulesen und die worte
zu lernen auch genau und mit dem haus
macht was ist ein lieblingswort was
dubai sie gerne gelernt hast so das ist
schwer
hammer ist sehr gut aber cool oder
hammerl acker und und was sonst ja ich
glaube ich weiß nicht jetzt so das ist
geil aber ohne scheiß wir müssen das man
öfter ankündigen also ich habe jetzt
gerade erfahren werden uns nicht
zufällig getroffen sondern wir haben
gestern gepostet bei facebook dass wegen
klein sind und ihr habt ein bisschen
ausschau gehalten kann man das sagen ja
wir haben
der dom mal drei oder viermal um geläuf
tunke dom herum gelaufen
vier oder fünf mal um ihr zu finden um
euch zu finden euch zu verdanken
interessant wie man das gemacht wir
haben ich habe schon mal früher überlegt
ob wir immer ankündigen wo wir drehen
ich habe das einmal gemacht und keiner
ist gekommen deswegen mache ich das
nicht mehr aber es ist sehr schön dass
du gekommen
ja es war sehr sehr gut was zwei fragen
noch was gefällt dir am meisten an die
zusammen das man aber so 22 dinge 1 1
dass man die text lesen können
da könnt kann
kann und auch
die
das ist cool und zweite reihe ist was
gefällt dir nicht so gut oder was können
wir noch verbessern aus deiner sicht ja
das weiß ich nicht ist es das weiß nicht
ist es ist so gut an einige de hast du
schon oder ein thema was du gerne
verschiedene arten von bier vielleicht
haben gerade eine sache gelernt also ich
hab das gelernt und das hast du auch ich
wusste das selber nicht hier in köln die
prävention also erstmal sind diese biere
extrem klein für anders also viele leute
aus anderen regionen verlagern und man
hat dann schon immer angst dass das
spiel so schnell leer ist das habe ich
den fehler gemacht ich erstmal zwei
bestellt aber hier gibt situationen mein
benutzt den bierdeckel wenn man so macht
signalisiert man man möchte erstmal kein
neues wenn man das nicht macht bekommt
man automatisch neues wenn es fast leer
es ist das nicht toll das ist toll ich
liebe diese tradition
verfolgt es geht schnell also demnächst
kommt auch noch eine episode von uns zum
thema als kölsche kultur kölner dialekt
ich freue mich darf danke dass du mir
was ich danke vielmals